مساحه صغيره تبقت للسيطره على بخموت بشكل
كامل تقديرات قائد مجموعه فاجنر تقول انها
اقل من ثلاثه كيلومترات سنبا
خ مود
يقول
مساحه يبدو انها اتعبت يفجين بريجوجين حتى
دفعته الى التلويح والتهديد بالانسحاب من
المدينه تصريحات المتضاربه حول بقائه من
عدمه في بخمت تلقاه الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان
قادر اوف وابدا استعداده لارسال قواته
ليحلوا محل مجموعه باجنر رغبه لم يفوتها
قائد فاجنر طلب من موسكو السماحه بتسليم
مواقع قوته للقوات الشيشانيه
مواقف تظهر ان بريكوجين ماضن في تنفيذ
تهديداته بالانسحاب من بخموت في العاشر من
مايو فالرجل اتهم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بتجاهل طلباته لامداد قوته بالذخيره وهو
ما وافقه عليه قاديروف مذكرا بما كانت
تواجه قوته من نقص بامدادات الدفاع
الروسيه لا سيما في معارك ماريوبول و
لوغانسك
وفيما تتصاعد الازمه بين الرجال بوتين
الاقوياء والمؤسسات العسكريه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان وحدتها الهجوميه تواصل
التقدم في الجزء الغربي من باخمت
اما في موسكو فلم يعلق الكرملين على ازمه
رجل بوتين القوي والغاضب لكنه اكد علمه
بما ينويه بريكوجين لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات